Happy birthday, hair's on fire.
And what is this dog worried about?
Oh great.
It's episode 43 of IMG!
Say "cheese."
Oh. Also on Tumblr this week I found
this price sticker.
Oh Pooh.
Here's an awesome plan I found on "dvice."
Not designs for a skyscraper,
but for an Earth scraper
in Mexico City; an inverted building that
goes down into the ground,
300 meters deep.
We've all seen contrails before,
clouds formed when the vapour in hot
airplane exhaust cools high up in the cold
air and the moisture
condenses, but there's also the opposite
of a contrail. When a plane flies low enough
through a cloud that
already exists and its hot exhaust turns
the visible water
back into water vapour, making a distrail, a racing part of the cloud.
Wow, look at these legs on
Spain's Minister of Defense.
Are her feet on the wrong legs?
I mean, the big toe
on your right foot is on the left,
but hers is on the right...?
Well, it turns out it's actually an optical illusion.
Her legs are not actually crossed.
MoIllusions.com explains it with this.
.gif break.
MoIllusions.com, by the way, is a great
site if you're not already checking it
out frequently.
Earlier this week it covered cinemagraphs,
a special artistic type
of animated .gif where video has been frozen
and only a small portion of it is
allowed to still be
a motion picture.
The effect is quite dramatic
and beautiful.
This is an advertisement for tires,
but maybe also for pandas?
And the only thing worse than being
alone is being watched.
Eeyore's nose is a cute little
face and in earlier episode I talked
about cats
wearing bread.
Well, according to BuzzFeed, they are now
also wearing tortillas, pitas and the birds
are catching on.
Of course, proper dental care is the real feline
challenge, so let's take a moment
for cats brushing their own teeth.
Owls can be pretty darn scary,
but charts, on the other hand, can be
pretty darn informative.
I love charts has analyzed
the Alanis Morissette's idea of
"Irony," as well as mathematical dance moves.
And this helpful chart showing powers of 10
from one septillionth
to one septillion. They also pointed
me to a recipe for tiramisu on Cooking
for engineers.com.
Rather than list directions,
this method flows from left to right
grouping actions to ingredients. People like
getting their picture taken as they fall down
Splash Mountain
and we've all seen the funny planned
poses, but this game cube one was new
to me
and the shades are really what makes it.
Oh, there it is.
My tongue cleaner with guaranteed export
quality. Just as nice of course
are these shoes: metal detectors, keyboards,
aliens and sandwiches;
which I like to put inside bags that
make them look mouldy,
covered in bugs or make my lunch a notebook,
a pair of jeans or comfy, comfy felt.
Chart Bin is another great info fix source.
Their interactive nuggets of wisdom show off
things like the only countries that
border
only one other country or which side of
the road
people drive on by country.
In the United States,
we drive on the right hand side. In the
UK and Ireland they drive on the left and
in Spain they drive on the right,
but in Kenya they drive on the left,
which is where I am
right now. Nairobi, Kenya. There's some
really great YouTubers out here doing some
cool stuff and I put some links to my favorites
in the description. The same site
also has a global map,
where you can mouse over a country to see
its national flag. I've been busy trying
to memorize the flags of
all these countries using the National
Flag's quiz app on my phone,
but this site is awesome 'cause it also gives you
the reason the flag looks the way it
does.
Interesting fact: the flag of Mozambique
is the only flag on
Earth that has a modern weapon on it.
That's right. It's got an AK-47
on the flag representing their
independence. Pretty neat, right?
And as always,
thanks for watching.